all in all Foodies the foodie land Night
Market has arrived in Las Vegas for a
two-week instant the outdoor Festival
features food shopping and live
entertainment Madison Kimbrough joins us
live from the Las Vegas Motor Speedway
tonight with the latest Madison
yeah Sasha if only the smell of all this
great food could be transported through
the television take a look at the crowd
here at the foodie land Night Market as
this Festival arrived in Vegas on Friday
tonight it will last until 10 p.m and
admission is just five bucks online this
West Coast exclusive event takes place
here in Nevada and California through
October and has over 150 vendors that
Foodies can choose from so from Japanese
to Italian to Mexican we even saw a
Coffee Joint a bunch of desserts too
Festival goers sharing with us why they
decided to make the trip out on this
Sunday
I want to try all the meats the proteins
chicken the steaks the beefs and
anything like that and churros you know
food is one of those things that brings
most people together so this is why we
figured we'd come try it out and see
what they have
tickets and while the food takes Center
Stage here small businesses and
boutiques are the heart of the event too
with live entertainment set for tonight
so remember if you can't come tonight
this Festival lasts until next weekend
too on Saturday and Sunday we'll have a
list of all the dates and times up on
our website later this evening gotta
send it back to you